what do you think the story of egypt is
well i think
that that there was a pre-cataclysmic
civilization on our planet right that
uh existed prior to maya
egypt and inca and so on timeline wise
where would that put up
it would be like 12 000 years ago prior
to the last
um the meltdown of the last ice age
which
might have been this reporting all
around the world of these ancient
civilization about
the great flood right where the the
water rose
prior to these event there may have been
a civilization on our
planet that left monuments all around
the world
that was maybe quite advanced
and advanced in a different way that
were advanced today
with technology that might have
surpassed
what we're capable of doing today seems
like it
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is nasim haramin
to start off our two-part series uh
we're going to dive into egypt since i
just got back from egypt
and he has so much knowledge about egypt
and ancient
civilizations where it all came from and
what really happened
in the science we talked about the
temples about the pyramids
just what the heck was going on in
ancient egypt enjoy
i think like i'd like to be able to
snowboard and ski
yeah it's great to be if there was like
steep and deep
yeah it would be fine right for
snowboarding
yeah but the rest of the time socially
yeah
skiing is so much more functional yeah
it is
it is yeah um okay so i just went to
egypt and got back
um last week and uh in
listening to more of your
talks and information i was like oh my
gosh you know all about
egypt this would be the perfect time
to ask what the hell is egypt all about
because
right in my like recent uh
exposure yeah i'm like i literally just
said to myself when people ask me how it
was
i think they were expecting me to come
back with some sort of like giant
epiphany or some magical experience or
something and maybe i was too
on some level like maybe that'll happen
but i wasn't looking for that
um but all i could say when i came back
is i was like
we just don't get it right we don't
we're not asking the right questions
i'm not even sure we have the right we
know the right question to ask
exactly it's so gigantic it's so
it's such a big enigma that it's
actually hard to figure out
like what exactly happened there and
uh how did it actually get done because
i mean everybody knows about the
pyramids and all this and
a lot of people know about the stats of
the pyramids and how they're
incredibly precise and all these things
but there is so much
more you know you go to saqqara you go
to the european you go to so many places
you know along the nile and so on and
you see
things that are just remarkable that are
not easily explained
uh in terms of ancient civilization
with copper tools and vine ropes with
like a few hundred thousand slaves
yeah right let's just pull that giant
monolithic size
stone up here and wait that's just one
of a bajillion of them that we're going
to get right
here exactly it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't and
why would you want to build like that
you know civilizations
built with the means of their technology
at the time you know
you you know even today we use bricks
that are easily carry you know from one
place to the other wait the giant people
do you think it was giant people well
there's stories about giants from all
around the world
right uh it could be
that they were very large people at one
point on the planet they
they're in the cultural myth all around
the world from
societies that didn't know each other uh
and uh that should not have
the same ideas you know and then as well
you see
uh same type of arc uh architecture
all around the world as well like why
were they all building pyramids and
we're finding more and more it's not
like there's a few
thousands yeah and how many are covered
right now exactly right how many are
covered by
trees and bushes and you know you look
out and you're like that
mountain looks perfect yes
actually they're just using new
technology radar technology they're
starting to map out in southern
mexico and guatemala and so on
the jungle and they're finding thousands
and thousands of pyramids that they
didn't know was there
and they're saying oh my god there must
have been a population of millions of
people
in this region and um you know it like
the conventional
archaeological explanation of you know
these uh kind of like um
very you know low technological
technologically advanced civilization um
and and low cultural
you know advanced um knowledge
is not consistent with what is being
found
all around the world so yeah and so you
got the same stories all around the
world you get the same
type of architecture around the world
and when
you look at the stories the stories
are very consistent they talk about
giants but they as well
talk about you know these giants come
you know coming from the stars
they talk about them as sun gods uh
and uh they talk about them coming in
vessels or
boats that floated in the air and so on
and so
you know i know this is controversial
but
when you look at the evidence it's
overwhelming
before we get into more specific
questions
there seems to be bridges connecting
science and mythology and
spirituality so how much
how much of the mythological stories
do uh drive the science
like where's the where's the
intersection there that makes you look
at something
and do you even believe in it at all
because being a scientist
you know that's their stories right
right but where do they come from
exactly and well you know if they were
really scarce and
they were very different across the
world from each other and
they didn't have any consistency and so
on you'd say well maybe they had a
really good
in those regions they had a really good
imagination
they come up with this all this stuff
right but
there is this thing about the
consistency and then
for me and this is certainly not the
typical path
for scientists especially not in physics
for me um i was very interested in
archaeology
i felt there was a great mystery and
um i was very much interested in in the
anomalies in archaeology
and um i could see
relationship between the physics i was
writing
and the symbolism that was found in all
these different cultures around the
world
uh left by the sun gods you know um
and for me it was like wait maybe
there's something to learn here about
the foundation of reality and
you know we have a tendency to live
in what i call like
you know linear view of reality
right right we we tend to be
um uh horizontal in our view right we do
our work every day
we go home we do the laundry take care
of the kids
do the cooking go to bed start over
again right
and so we and so it's like we have a cap
and we're just looking on the surface
right like
on on like a linear way and i
what i call i call this going vertical
so like to like blow the cap
and then take a like a maybe a galactic
view
of earth right well from the galaxy
earth doesn't even show up it's too
small
even the sun is too small but like
imagine
that you could like take a view from
like
the galactic perspective how much
possibility of life is there in the
galaxy you know
a lot i think that it's one of the most
um egotistical things to think that
we're the only existence in the universe
right and and and then you gotta
ask as well deeper questions it's like
well how did they all
get there right how do you get all there
like and how is it getting organized
so that in some miracle
you know 100 trillion cells would
continue to do
the same thing like duplicating exactly
the right way so i can keep
living right it's not just like oh it
happened
millions of years ago and we got like
biology going
it's continuing to happen every second
right you're dividing about
a million cells a second there's
billions
of chemical changes that are occurring
in your body continuously this
you know there's this incredible dynamic
of creation occurring for you to be able
to sit here
and look back at ancient citization or
look at physics and so on and
and wonder yeah about the nature of
reality
and so when you go vertical and you look
at it from that perspective
and then you look at these ancient
civilizations and the symbolisms they
left and the philosophy they laughed and
all this
and you look at advanced physics all of
a sudden you start to see
they converge and that was
my first gut feeling intuition early on
like 30 years ago and then i start
developing physics based on
on this understanding so i think there's
something
really profound in you know when you go
to these temples for instance in egypt
or
in maya country or in peru and so on
there's something profound and it's not
necessarily some spiritual awakening
that's gonna happen
it's just a realization that something
probably remarkable happen in the united
states
how are these temples built how were the
walls clad
with information and
the like there's no way somebody had a
little hammer and chisel like they're
perfect
i was like do they have a stamp did they
have a casting yet the pictures are
different all of it so
what what is it in a bigger overview
like what do you think egypt
where what do you think the story of
egypt is well i think
that and we're discovering this more and
more many many researchers are
are working on this but that there was a
pre-cataclysmic
civilization on our planet right that
uh existed prior to maya
egypt and inca and so on timeline wise
where would that put up
it would be like 12 000 years ago prior
to the last
um the meltdown of the last ice age
which
might have been this reporting all
around the world of easy's ancient
civilization about
the great flood right where the the
water rose
uh dramatically all around the world and
and
you know so prior to this event
there may have been a civilization on
our planet
that left monuments all around the world
that was maybe quite advanced
and advanced in a different way that
were advanced today
um with technology that might have
surpassed what we're capable of doing
today
seems like it yes because many of those
pieces we see around the world are
not something we could reproduce with
all of our cranes and
all of our advanced cnc technology and
so on
we can't take uh you know like
the statues that are a thousand ton
right we can't take a thousand ton
uh granite or dried statue which is
almost as hard as diamond
and put it in the cnc and carve the face
of a pharaoh
so it's perfectly symmetric and so i'm
like we can't do that
there's a lot of evidence that's piling
up
about this earlier civilization that may
have
left us very important
pieces of information about the nature
of reality
the nature of consciousness um
and the nature like advanced technology
that could free humanity from uh
from the bondage of being stuck on the
surface of a planet for instance with
limited resources
and we're arriving at a very important
time in our evolution where we have to
do something
dramatic to uh to learn to
produce energy in a sustainable way
to learn to you know motivate
you know move ourselves in a sustainable
way
and so on and so on and i think maybe
some of these ancient
uh sets of knowledge are
present to help us with this moment one
baseline thing that i came away
with was that in exploring these temples
and we went to a
ton i mean it was two weeks of touring
[Music]
i mean like the hathor temple like
there's a sort of
canal like they would call it like a
birthing canal that goes down and splits
right it was daytime when we were there
and it's dark but of course they've now
had to
run power down there and it you know
running it on the floor with lights
there's nothing on the walls about fire
electricity that's right there's nothing
in there to tell you like how did they
see
and the walls are covered with
information so it's like
i was in there during the day so i'm
like
what did they what did they do for light
right
that's a big question actually i you
know it's hard to answer that question
there's no
you know some thoughts was that they
were using mirrors of the time but
mirrors of the time
what does that mean well well you know
mirrors in the right angle to reflect
the sun
into where they were going but um you
know mirrors at the time
were not reflecting light very well and
they were you know it wouldn't have
worked um in some of those areas i mean
when you go into
some of the pyramids you're hundreds of
feet below the ground you know like
the serpium i mean there's all kinds of
places under sakura there's a chamber
that's
almost like maybe eight story high
with the with the juried box in the
middle that's
enormous almost two-story high during
box that
um made out of 64 62 pieces
each one weighing over 100 ton over
500 ton and so on i mean it's just
it's not conceivable that you could do
it that way
and then you know at the atar temples uh
recently they were doing repairs on the
floor and they found that there is
you know these huge um uh
pillars yes they're huge they're huge
gigantic right i mean
never mind the walls covered in
everything the pillars and all the
temples are
grandiose they're gigantic they're on
the outside they're on the inside
yeah and you're like that small beside
it yeah it's like wait why did they make
the ceiling so high
right why are the pillars so big yeah um
because that'd be hard to do
um well now they've found uh that
it seems like there is the same pillars
underneath meaning that the the temple
we see today is built on top
of another one that's what the guides
were saying is that like they were
all all of these are built on top of old
old temples
right that are even older yes right so
then
that would be the temples i'm talking
about from the earlier
pre-cataclysmic and you you see
this is where there's been some
confusion in archaeology
uh you see that in peru very clearly um
you know we assign certain
buildings and certain monuments to
the egyptian or to the incas or the
mayas and so on
but when you actually look at these
monuments
you can see what was repaired
and what was original and you can see
the repairs you are
you know of a quality much lower
than the original and so
we've assigned the same dates from the
repairs
to the original and and uh and
when i was in egypt and in peru and so
on i was pointing that out to the guides
some of them being you know
archaeologists that are
well seasoned and so on yeah and they
were
they were noticing you know especially
in peru's
oh now i get it you know
inca priyanka you
and so you know um
some of the technologies that are
one like for instance these walls in
ianka country in peru which
where the stones seem to have been
melted
onto each other so that they're perfect
very complex puzzle
not one stone is the same i have a
picture literally like in
machu picchu in the ruins and it's like
a perfect like notch and it's all just
like it's like
a slightly beveled edge and everything
meets up perfectly you're just like
how'd they do that exactly why why would
it just be flat like if they're stacking
stones
right why are you why you got a notch
here uh-huh yeah
and then there's theories that they had
moles and they were
like in egypt that they were they were
using limestone
powder and making the blocks right um
but
then you look at the pyramids and not
one block is the same size
so you would have to make two million
three hundred thousand
moles you know so that doesn't make
sense right if you got a mole you make
them all the same and then you
and it was smooth too the outsides of
the pyramids were smooth right
yeah they were they look like they're
stacked right now as blocks and there's
edges
but originally it was smooth yeah that
was the inner
rough layer that we see uh on on top was
a layer of
uh limestone that was perfectly smooth
and
perfectly the the few box blocks that
are left you can see the
joints are perfect and so on and
that was mined to build you know early
caro
you know it was mined off the pyramid so
there's not so many blocks that remains
but yeah
the big question that i have and let's
separate them
because they feel like they're different
is the purpose of the temples
and the purpose of the pyramids yeah
because of course the temples were
you know mostly all obviously you know
open
and there's rooms and but they're very
open and
of course there's some places you can go
underneath a little bit but um and
there's probably even more
connecting things here and there
especially when you get into luxor
and connecting certain things
underground and of course they
you know the thought of the pyramids and
the sphinx and everything became
connected underground
but the temples seemed to serve a
different purpose they were also
clad with all the stories and the
rituals and the offerings and the
you know accomplishments and everything
that's all over the place but then you
go to the pyramids
and the pyramids are just the pyramid
there's nothing there's not a thing on
the wall
so the difference between the temples
and the pyramids but let's go with the
temple since that's what we're talking
about
what were they for well i think that
um the two were connected
like you were saying they found they
found
underground tunnels you know that
connect everything
i mean and it's pervasive meaning
there's more and more tunnels being
found every day
and you know and not everything is
published you know i was
i was fortunate to be
in the presence of various
let's just say you know official agents
uh you know when i was in those regions
that showed me maps of what they
what's under there that's remarkable but
this uh so so they seem to have been
connected like a big
it just looked like a big circuit board
you know when you looked at the map it
just looked like a you
i i i make circuit boards in my
laboratory you know electronic boards
look just like that with components you
know and then connections and all this
the traces and all this like it it
looked like a huge
resonant you know yeah
uh electronic circuit that connected
and so i think the pyramids might have
been
a power source you see yeah and the
temple
would have been the place where
the you know the consciousness and the
spiritual awareness and all this
or the the higher you know path of
initiation was happening
because you see science
and this is finally occurring in physics
you can't really divorce
consciousness from reality
um we are made out of atoms and protons
and electrons and
neutrons and and cells and all this and
we have this thing that we call
self-awareness and consciousness
is kind of a weird word because it's
really not well defined you know it's
like what is that
right but why everybody keeps writing
about it yeah
what is it what is it right exactly um
so i like to use self-awareness it gives
more of an understanding like some kind
of feedback
um but uh but
so this you know
let's say you're having an evolution in
which a civilization
maybe even bypasses uh
the mechanical like
uh industrial revolution that we went
through
okay and goes right to
quantum entanglement right and
and and uses it yeah and uses it right
and and
gravity control and you know all this
right
and and that's conceivable right
it is um it's not
that we don't see that that's a
possibility
it's just we went a very specific
trajectory and it might have been a
little bit of a detour so let's say
there's another civilization
that did something a little different
and
uh you see they would arrive at a place
of understanding of the physics of the
universe that would include the
evolution of consciousness
right that would include what we might
call spirituality today
but that is just like physics we haven't
understood yet
right the nature of awareness the nature
of consciousness the nature of
being able to like transcend
your you know linear experience to like
going vertical and maybe you know having
a deeper uh integration with the
universe
right so that you're not thinking oh i'm
just a little thing that's
kind of like separate from everything to
oh
you know my physics my technology and
everything is showing me i'm actually
part
of this amazing will works of nature
and i'm you know i'm an intricate
part of it i i'm i'm the universe
learning about myself right
and that leads to a very
different kind of technology right it
leads to a very difficult
kind of interaction human interaction
with each other and so on and so
if you look at these ancient
civilization and and you think
technology and advanced consciousness
right you would see something like
pyramids that could be power plants
right right
so there's no writing in them because
it's a power plant
right that's exactly what i thought
going into the great pyramid and
going into the king's chamber like it
was super
there's a lot of people on this trip
that were able to sort of sense
different things and there's clear
everything right like so but i feel
frequency pretty easily so you go into
the king's chamber and
or is it called king's chamber to king's
chamber and
um he's not living that the tombs are in
the
you know valley of the kings yeah they
never found any mummies no
they're pyramids no yeah and so but you
go in
and the frequency is so high and i
thought
these were like energy centers right
that's what they felt like to me too
because the frequency was high there's
nothing
adorning the walls there's no comfort
there's no beauty even on so i mean it's
cool it's interesting
right but it's not aesthetically like
somewhere you'd be like oh do you want
to have tea in the queen's chamber today
no no no it's not one of those no maybe
in the temple
over there yeah exactly exactly
um but it felt like that to me too and
you know i had a lot of thoughts about
the tops of the pyramid and like the top
of
kofu the great pyramid isn't even there
do we know where
it is no okay so what do you think it is
because i had plenty of thoughts about
that
oh well i mean i just had random
thoughts about like why don't we know
where it is
right and what purpose did it serve why
wouldn't it still be there
right well you know um
there is multiple depiction
of there's not that many depiction first
of all of the pyramids
and all these walls that are adorned
like they don't even have like i mean
right that's right so there's only a few
places where they were found
and in in those cases which
made the archaeologists think that the
the the cap of the pyramid was made out
of gold
it shows the cap radiating light
okay to of course to an archaeologist in
the 1800s
the first thought might be oh it must be
reflective
surface could be gold right right
i don't quite come to the same
conclusion
uh you're a scientist but what's your
opinion because it's hard to prove these
things right
right yes my opinion is that
the power source that so
i was privileged to be able in the to be
in the pyramid
by myself for you know for hours
in the middle of the night and yeah i
i i was just tuning and humming just
yep toning yeah toning just like really
light
beautiful yeah just to see like
how does it resonate this chamber right
how does this cavity resonate
and it was just remarkable yeah uh
because that goosebumps thinking about
it
you did the same thing yeah because i
had groups coming in and out
you know for um two hours at the time
but in between the groups had these
moments alone
and as soon as the group the last people
would exit the pyramid
when i was toning all of a sudden the
resonance would change
and it was just remarkable i could feel
the whole
the whole pyramid you were talking a lot
of tonnage of material
yeah yeah resonating and people outside
said i could hear you toning and i'm i'm
always stoning like
really quietly you know and so
it was just so so
think of the pyramid maybe as a
resonating cavity
right and think of the technology
that would be very advanced right that
would be
a technology that has gravitational
effects a technology that's extracting
energy from space-time you know
very advanced technology like a warp
drive or something like that
well that technology would be
a resonance link to the structure of
space time and
i just okay i'm so excited today because
i just finished solving these equations
literally yesterday
and i'm i'm just blown away we're right
on time
i'm just blown away like yesterday i
literally
i didn't but i felt like jumping
cheering i know this is not oh thank you
whatever you want but all we've got is
coffee and tea right now
that's fascinating i mean yeah share
whatever you
would like to share yeah we can talk
about that but imagine this technology
being
so advanced
because it's tapping into the structure
of reality
tapping into this well that is a
resonance match it's like a
radio being tuned to the right frequency
so that all of a sudden it's like and
then the whole pyramid is like an
antenna
right the whole thing is just
and then those pyramids are on
huge um uh limestone
slabs yeah the biggest in the world
right
yeah yeah one of the biggest and
if they weren't they would have sunk
right because they're so
heavy right so like the white house sunk
like six inches and it's much
younger right he has the app what are
they aren't they called uh abalos what
is that what are the spear the spire
spears
the oh at the front of the temple yeah
what are the no the
in karnak incarnate what are those
called those that
they um they're like the spot
the one in dc is from egypt right that's
crazy
okay sorry i just had to mention that
because i thought that was fascinating
there's one in london
there's one in england uh yeah in london
there's one in france in paris
right and then there's a replica in dc
right
they make some kind of grid yes
well i think at the time they were
definitely antennas at the entrance of
the temple
so that because these things are highly
tuned you know the one in karnak that's
still standing
yeah that thing is huge right yes it's
like
500 ton made out of granite it's
perfectly straight yeah
but they didn't miss like a beat there's
things designed into that too it's clad
with information
exactly all the way up and when you look
closely
it's perfect right it's perfect and
there's many that are fallen mostly
because
the europeans try to take some to bring
back to london and
and and france and they tried to take
the big ones at first and they realized
they couldn't take those because they're
too big
but when they fell them they broke and
stuff but
basically you can go to the nose of one
of those
and hit it and the whole thing
resonates like a tuning fork yeah
exactly so now think of what i was
telling you about the pyramids this
power resource that's resonating the
whole thing
it's on a huge you know it's on
the earth crust ringing right and then
all the obelisks at the temple are
capping the signal right
and free energy yeah this is their like
i mean i
i don't know i mean i you look at like
the ankh right i had to wear my flower
of life because i want to talk about
because i had this made because i've
always resonated with the flower of life
um but the ankh being like looking like
the nikola tesla
right you know coyotes and it's like
they are picked like pictures of them
holding an
ankh all the time and i get it the
original cross is the sort of
you know whatever possibility of course
and
but then what is is it also energy was
this also part of their energy
yeah i mean the original cross thing is
i think inaccurate because you know like
they hadn't
used they hadn't
transformed it into a torturing device
yet
okay but uh you know um
i just yeah but but you can
think of what was it then okay it's not
it's not the original cross then what
was it
why are people holding that in every
picture right why is why
why am i wearing this exactly they might
have been
technology specific like i was saying
you know you have to think of the
technology in a different way than when
you think of technology mechanics today
and stuff like that it's
it's probably a different level of
technology that we don't well understand
but for instance the pyramids are made
of mostly silica
right like this is it's a huge crystal
right and
we we use crystals in our technology
today
because the oscillator oscillates well
right so
they're in our computers in our phones
and everything else
like all microchips are running off
these little
crystal waivers the amount of informa
it's from what i understand
you can there's a lot of information
that can be held in a crystal right
well yeah that's true well it depends
how you define
information yes but we definitely use
oscillating crystals in all of our
electronics
okay right so so imagine a civilization
that's using an
oscillating crystal crystal but it's the
size of a pyramid
right so then the parasol source that's
oscillating that thing
is a different level of energy
than our little batteries in our
computers and
or you know so also in your pineal gland
it's crystals in the pineal gland
right yes there's there's liquid crystal
in there
yes and we're like our own avalor yeah
obviously yeah you can
you can imagine the body as being a
bio crystal oscillator and certainly all
your bones are piezoelectric like
crystals
when you walk that you know they produce
electric fields and
you know there's uh this is why if you
go in space you start deteriorating if
you don't have gravity because
you need that piezoelectric effect you
know
to keep all your tendons and your
muscles
activated and so on and so it's really
you know like i said all of a sudden if
you
reach the vertical level of technology
if you think about it
what it could be then it start to all
kind of come together
right right maybe they weren't just
thinking of energy as
electric fields to light up something
which they might have been able to do
in a way that didn't require wires right
um like which nikola tesla
did as well yes yes wireless
transfer of energy is absolutely
possible it's been reproduced
but um but you can think as well as
maybe they were energizing the human
crystal
you know right as well that they were
bringing
you know high level of coherency and so
on maybe
they could extend life you know maybe
uh maybe they could reginate regenerate
cells and so on and and that might
explain as well
they're huge uh later
in the dynasty intent on trying to
preserve the crystal of the body
right because when you look at how they
and bond which we don't understand in
modern
uh chemistry today how they embold the
body so that they would preserve so well
and so on
um you know we can't replicate that oh
no
we have you know there is there is
secrets that we can't figure out how
they did it
you know uh in terms of preservation of
the tissues and so on it's remarkable
um and so there is
you know so maybe they were wanting to
preserve
the crystalline nature of the body for
you know certain purposes in the future
and so on
it's hard to tell it's hard to say
and this might sound really very
esoteric
but i assure you i'm talking to you
about this
coming from a perspective of physics and
you know and
a standard physicist may not even
understand
what i mean by a perspective of physics
there
because it's beyond the standard model
however we're starting to
discover this place beyond the standard
model
and much of it has to do with what i've
been talking to you about
meaning that there's information in
space-time
there's energy and space-time and
there's a source of reality
that is a field that connects everything
that everything is entangled
you know that black holes are not these
huge monsters that just appear in the
middle of galaxy but that they
are part of the evolution of creation
and so on so this very very
deep level of physics that are emerging
from those thoughts i was talking to you
so i guess at the end of the day because
there's this is all
fascinating and it's fun and we talk
about it but it's like
i always think to myself okay what does
this what does this mean
you know what do we learn from like
going to egypt and seeing you know i
love the
the joke in my head i've been thinking
since i was there is it's like
you know the writing's on the wall it's
like it literally
is what are we
missing so what what is it that inspires
you the most
and leads you down a rabbit hole
from ancient egypt
well i think awe
of being there and seeing these things
and that i think if you study them for
many years
as i did and you and you never actually
go there and see it
yeah uh you you're missing you you have
to go and see it it's just
you just have to see it yeah it's all
inspiring yeah
and you you really get the the sense
of the enormous you know the enormous
task that it would take to put these
things together but yeah
um i think that uh i think
the key is that
first of all to realize and you know
more and more archaeologists in egypt
and in you know south america are
starting to
are agreeing that they must have been
a pre-cataclysmic civilization
this is becoming almost a standard
in archaeologic you know in egyptology
over there um you know now
this um i think
is telling us i think what can we get
out of this i think
what we can get out of this is that
there's something
way beyond um oh we were microbes and
then the microbes got together
and then they made a monkey and then you
know the monkey started walking
on two feet and you know like it became
some kind of you know homo sapien sapien
and
somehow the homo sapiens sapiens start
to become
self-aware and you know that there is
something
deeper i mean that story might be true
but the fact that it happened was not
some kind of random event but that there
is
a deeper you know evolutionary
pulse in in in
reality in in our world in in the
physicality of our world
like in the i'm talking not some
spiritual thing but
actually in the atoms that you're made
of
right that like these things are
carrying information
and that evolutions are cyclical
you know totally and that the stories in
egypt are
cyclical like you look at the story of
isis and osiris and
the you know immaculate conception of
horus
and then you look at mary and the
immaculate conception of jesus like the
cycle like you
you start to hear the back story further
and further in front of you like wow
i've heard that story before yes i mean
like just as an example that i
that i heard there you find it in the
vedic tradition you find
everywhere you know maya anka so on you
you
find the same stories so you see these
um the cyclical dynamics
of evolution and you start to think okay
you know where could we go from here
you know maybe we need to go it's like
literally like
back to the future let's say maybe we
need to like
understand what happened then
so that we can move forward now right so
that we can
and that was really my thought three
years ago
uh and that's why i was not able to
study inside the institution so well
because i was too interested on
the subject that were very you know
considerably
unrelated and um and i wanted to have
that flexibility to study whatever i
wanted so
and so i think at the deeper level
uh it will lead us to understanding the
nature
of our existence and the nature of
reality
and that might sound like an
unconceivable
notion this is my dream
to understand that right well you know
and
and why not right like
we we came out of this reality
why would we not have the knowledge on
how
it actually made us how you know how we
got here
what it is how it works and to become
harmonic with it like the idea you know
that there is not enough energy for
everybody and that we have to fight for
it
you know that we have to go to war and
so on for territorial disputes or for
energy or for resources um you know
it's not congruent with what you observe
in the universe
right you know the universe is very
energetic
yeah you know you look at the star
it's it's outputting some serious juice
you know it's like so are you and i
right heart
your heart produces i don't know the
numbers but it's a
tremendous amount of energy correct um
you burn at almost a hundred
fahrenheit all day long every day for
like
80 years yeah 100 years hopefully oh
maybe 150 years
ago yeah a thousand who knows who knows
right but it's like
it's an it's a very dynamic energetic
universe
every atom every proton has been
spinning since the beginning of time
you know and it doesn't slow down it
doesn't
go oh you know i'm running out of energy
i didn't pay my bill
you know whatever yeah yeah exactly
it keeps going yeah going and going it's
like
way better than the energizer bunny and
it
you know and you look at the universe
not only is it continuing to expand
it's not slowing down as it's expanding
which you'd expect if it was entropic
and so on
it's actually accelerating exactly yeah
so
so we live in an extremely energetic
system we tend to
think that um we have to scrounge to get
energy but
it might be that if we understand
actually the
nature of the source of this energy that
produce
all this yeah reality uh
then we would have
uh infinite amount of energy so then the
the
the capping question on it is
is there something suppressing that is
there somebody suppressing that
are there is there more of a
sort of evil
selfish egotistical
group or entity or that is
like withholding this information i was
thinking to myself when we were talking
about the cap to the pyramid and i was
thinking like
you look on the back of the dollar right
and it has the
cap with an eye with an eye
what's in there and where is the cap do
they have the cap
hidden underground what are they doing
with it like i
am playful i know you're a scientist but
i i look at these
like from a layman's perspective i look
at these like little signs and you're
like
why would what does this all mean you
know because it seems
crazy that we don't know where we came
from
we don't understand so much about
whether it be ancient egypt or the
origins and
the nature of like why don't we know
this why are we using fossil fuels like
there's so much that's like why
so is there a resistance beyond just our
knowledge
or is it really just egypt is inspiring
and now we're at we're starting to ask
the right questions
um i think you know you're yes and yes
you're
you're right that um there's been
resistance
and there's been straight up you know
cover-up um and people have lost their
lives right um you know and
um and there's been a lot of
um uh different
behaviors that are have slowed down the
evolution of humanity
right however i like to think of it
in the context of an evolution right
we're a young species
right we just started on our little path
as a more advanced technological
community you know like 150 years ago
the idea that you could get into a metal
object
and fly across the country and end up
you know a few hours later in new york
was like
unthinkable right now we do it every day
we don't think twice about it
um so so we're really young
and um of course there is
interest that were built on certain
infrastructure
that could be very disrupted if all of a
sudden we could extract energy
out of the structure of space anywhere
you are and massive amount of it
or never mind that you would have a
gravitational drive and you can go and
orbit jupiter for the weekend
right so sounds fun yeah could be fun
you know resistance is always gonna be
there although
resistance is futile right i mean we're
gonna go along with the program
or we're gonna get recycled by nature
right
uh so that's right yeah and and so we're
at that point
where um we have this opportunity
and that's why i'm so excited about the
equations i solved yesterday
which is the result of you know many
years of
working on this specific part yeah
but basically you know
this is we have this opportunity
to transcend this level of technology
and that's uncomfortable for people it's
normal it's uncomfortable like it's
uncomfortable for people
that have been taught or have been
teaching
all these years a certain set of
doctrines a certain instead of
understanding a certain set of ways of
looking at the universe to all of a
sudden
get uprooted and oh you know maybe
it wasn't quite the egyptian that built
this stuff or maybe
you know the laws of thermodynamics or
the laws of
conservation of energy are correct
but we don't live in a closed system so
there's an open system so that means
there's information that can flow
through the system and
we have access to it right so it's just
that change that transformation in our
mentality can
produce some resistance and and some
difficulty in society but
and i think we're right there there's a
new generation of scientists and
archaeologists and all this that are
coming up that are
you know they are wanting the truth
and they're looking for it and they're
pure in their
region this is leading into now like the
nature of reality which is
absolutely like my fascination i wake up
every day and i think to myself
what am i what are we what
is this what is this cup what's
happening
am i literally create am i creating my
reality in a way that
is be like i everything like i have a
saying that i've like my life's my fault
all the good and the bad right so am i
just perpetuating my reality are we
zeros and ones like my head
like spins on this the micro macro are
we
you know things seem to make sense when
you look at it from
uh you know that perspective uh or at
least
look at it like it's just con
i'm just so confused and perplexed by it
and
um which is why i love what you have to
say
um so maybe starting with the simple
question of
like what are we as a human
oh that's a simple question great oh my
god like
what are we because at the end of the
day the answering these questions
helps you know how to live your life
well you know what you are
yeah because like that'd be the question
like a lot of people would wonder why
does it matter well it matters because
it's how you're going to live your life
yeah like if you know that you could if
you know you can create your future
well wouldn't you do something about it
like instead of letting life happen to
you it's going to you're going to
control it
right so anyway that's why my
fascination is is because it's going to
help me live my life so
what are we okay um i wouldn't call that
a simple question but i'm
just gonna go for it you said it was
simple
yeah i didn't say it was so bad i think
it's super confusing i wake up every day
wondering
right what the nature of reality is all
about but let's start at least with the
body
so yeah we'll think of it as well the
thing the tendency is first of all to
think that
because we've been told this the
universe is random
right like there is no self-organizing
system can this be like chaos there
yeah oh no no chaos there is something
else but
generally the idea is that you see this
comes from a
really big intent in earlier times of
science to
separate science from religion
so religion said there's a god that's
organizing everything
and science needed to separate from that
so
so science went in the other direction
and said there's
nothing organizing it's all just random
and things collide with each other and
eventually
if we're lucky right and
if we're lucky is a big statement there
right
they are gonna agglomerate together and
somehow natural system will emerge from
it
and you know it's a good thought but
mathematically it's inconsistent meaning
mathematically the probability
of even just one monocellular system
would come to exist
after 13.7 billion years since
the beginning of the universe and you
know we could discuss that deeper yeah
that's next next is the big
bang for what might be the big bang
right right
and so basically but let's say we assume
the big bang
you know it doesn't add up you need
trillions and trillions of years
prior to the big bang for the
probabilities to work
out that somehow the complexity of
one cell would come to exist
right so that's already a big problem
right
and then if if it all of a sudden popped
out
and oops there was like a rock that fell
on it then it would take another
you know so yeah yeah so the probability
that it came
but the problem is that if you say that
to a physicist right away they're going
to assume you're religious
and that you're going to tell them it's
god that's organizing everything
right and what i'm saying is that
there's something in between
okay there's something different like
all together different
than these two options one it's
completely random there's no
organization
and the other one this god with
binoculars making sure everything is
good
right the the other option is that
there's
feedback meaning that there's a flow of
information this is
literally how i solve these equations i
was talking about
that there's a flow of information and
the flow of information that's
emanating from a system is called
electromagnetic fields
and the flow of information that is
collapsing into the system
right is called gravitational fields and
the relationship between the two
is a feedback that makes the system
self-organized it knows about its
environment
and it you know modifies itself it's
the theory of evolution of the quantum
world if you'd like
that eventually leads to the evolution
of biological system
because you're made out of 100 trillion
cells approximately
actually in your case most a little less
shorter
so because you're a small person
uh so maybe 30 minutes trillion you know
but let's say around there and each one
of these cells is made a hundred
trillion atoms
right so it's very complex system
and so all of a sudden but if you have
feedback you can get self-organizing
system to happen
very very quickly in evolution of a
system so you can start with a very
simple
set and get to a really complex set of
of interaction in very short amount of
time
um a good example is if i give a rubik's
cube to a blind person
and ask them to order it which is not
really a nice thing to do
if if they're moving a move every second
sounds like a joke yes but if they're
moving a move every second
it will take billions trillions
of years for them to randomly find the
solution
okay okay the probabilities are very
very low
okay almost zero yeah a rubik's cube is
way simpler than a human being
okay but if i
said to the blind person yes meaning
you're getting closer
and no just binary set of information
yes you're getting closer no you're not
getting further from the solution
it would take two and a half minutes and
they would order the
come on yes so you come on no as
absolutely
so maybe you can help me then uh
so you go from billions of years
randomly
to um or trillions of years to
you know a few minutes if you have
feedback
and so feedback systems so think of
yourself to answer your question because
it was a deep question
think of yourself as a feedback of
information
of the universe but i mean it literally
meaning
you're radiating thermodynamically right
so that's like information radiating
from you into the field
okay but you can think of the field you
know atoms are made of mostly space and
so on
so you can think of the field it's not
just outside of you but it's inside of
you
you're made out of 99.9 percent space
right so
so think of all their the little amount
we think we're firm
we think about what we're not we're like
just little mini tornadoes right like
exactly the body of tornadoes like the
cells are just
right yeah exactly we're not actually
matter no
yeah dense sense when you look at the
atoms you could say you're just
an electrostatic field of space right so
right so your space densified into a
thing right
like everything you touch everything you
know it's mostly space
right and and the thing we call not
space
it's just an electro static field that
bumps against each other
so it's like a little field in space
right and think of this little field
like a little sphere
exchanging the information between the
space inside
of it and the space outside of it and as
it does that it produces a little
thermodynamic effect that
we call our reality okay
so that's completely different view of
reality
and a completely different view of you
because you're basically a
set of information exchanging so you're
reading thermodynamically
and you're gathering information through
your senses right
so like the system learned to make you
more and more complex so you could have
more and more
awareness of your environment so you
could gather more and more information
and learn more and more feedback more
and more it's like a
continuous positive feedback of
complexity
and so like you have little black that's
why i was saying remember the top the
pyramids got the eye
when you said that i said well you
what's in the middle of an eye right
it's a little black dot
oh that's absorbing light right right
and sending those photons into your into
your cortex
into your brain right and then so
you're gathering information as you're
dispensing energy
so think of yourself as a conduit for
creation
right and and and so how you interpret
the information that comes in
is gonna dictate what you're gonna do
with the energy when you dispense it
like how are you gonna move your arm
how are you gonna how who are you gonna
talk to what you're gonna say
all this stuff right and in that sense
you are creating
your reality right because you're part
of this feedback loop
the thing that people forget is that
everybody's part of that field
everybody's part of that
loop so it's a collective creation
of our reality of our environment
right so it's not just you so although
you intend
to like do something really cool that
you want to do
it might not happen because there's
other people involved
right there's all the other things in
not just people like the chairs the wall
all the
other feedback loops that you're gonna
have to like
conjure you know you're gonna have
you're
going to have to get them to come along
with your plan
right yeah so that you can do the thing
you wanted to do
so so it's it's a dance it's a dance of
relationship
and it really if i could show you these
equations which i will
soon you know because uh we'll publish
them soon
it really shows that all there is is
relationships
right oh that is just an analogy for
life yes
all there is is is information exchange
at different scales and in different
ways
and that produces all the forces all the
constants of physics
everything we see is just this exchange
of information
all the bond angles that makes the
molecule that makes the cells and so on
so so you're so much more
vast than oh just a collection of cells
that somehow
randomly got together and became
self-aware you know by some
epic phenomena of your brain so this
says as well something
profound about you it says that you're
not the
bio crystal oscillator only
you're the information right it's not
happening all in your body meaning
you're exchanging
information with a field a quantum field
of information that goes
way beyond your your awareness
or your current capability thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button